all the pieces maybe you've just
finished filling out lots and lots of
different hiding units right and what
are those important things useful maybe
here in one unit and you want to change
into a different one you're going to be
able to compare things together or no
exact like how big is that really how
small so conversion is a really
important skill and it's the main one in
801 which you may like to write down now
before you forget okay so how does
conversion work for example if I told
you for instance there's a distance it's
2,000 meters and I want you to convert
from meters into kilometers how many
kilometers is that two thousand meters
what are you going to do with the number
2000 to turn it from meters into
kilometers
why do you reckon question okay so if
you had a number of meters if you wanted
to turn it into a number of kilometers
you should divide by a thousand and if I
went in Reverse what would I do if I was
going from kilometers to meters
I can't I'm gonna reverse yeah I can't
fantastic times by a thousand okay now
do you remember I was pointing out to
you how crazy confusing the imperial
system is ok now the crazy confusing
thing about the imperial system is
exactly what's beautiful and harmonious
about the metric system ok see these
numbers let's keep on going
if I told you I was one point seven
eight meters tall which roughly I am
okay how would you convert meters into
centimeters what would you do with that
1.78 number okay I multiply by a
thousand going here but I'm going to
multiply by a hundred he does that make
sense and then if I said to you okay
I've measured a link with my ruler it's
three point five centimeters okay
how would you convert that centimeters
into Millions
well lots of people renamed themselves
dustier than weekend
you thank you you would multiply by ten
okay now let me pause there before we
finish off this diagram I want you to
have a look down here if you're
converting to a smaller unit from
kilometers to meters or meters to
centimeters etc okay what are we doing
every time we have time Z when
multiplying right so if you're conveying
to a smaller unit what you need to
remember it is because they're smaller
you need lots of them so your number is
going to get bigger like one point seven
eight turning into a hundred and seventy
eight okay
so you need lots of them so multiply now
I want you to keep that in mind then in
two minutes tell me how to finish off
that next line how do I do the rest of
the conversions I'm missing a couple of
hours if I go from millimeters to
centimeters and centimeters to meters
I should what am I gonna do from
millimeters to centimeters divided by 10
or from centimeters to meters divided by
a hundred look at those numbers aren't
they beautifully systematic and easy to
remember question that's a really good
question
and I should probably know the answer
but I don't please find out for me and
then bring it back next lesson whom you
all know oh no will you reckon you've
gone on top please Nicola yep
give us a truck
uh-huh yep yep okay yes very good mean
is I'm really really big so you're not
going to use many offices right so I
think what's worth a fine you need less
of them so since they're getting smaller
you don't multiply you okay good so you
can see the easiest thing to get wrong
about this diagram is where do you
multiply identify which one am i doing
remember this this is what I like to
remember okay you look at a meter and
you say well that's got a lot of
centimeter and it's got even more
millimeters in it so if I'm converting
from a big unit to a really teeny one I
need lots of them that I multiply does
it say again Gabriel what country is he
from right ah of course because the
first people who implemented the
imperial system were the French after
the French Revolution yeah oh and
Australia only did it like centuries
later so it's a very old system